author of unholy trinity the vatican the
nazis and the swiss banks recently
talked about his book at the sarasota
reading festival in florida his book
examines the connections between the
vatican and the nazis and argue some
catholic officials protected nazi war
criminals from capture and punishment
during this 45-minute discussion mr
loftis describes his own involvement in
military intelligence u.s middle east
relations and why he wrote unholy
trinity
my name is deborah gessner i'm with the
florida holocaust museum in st
petersburg florida however i live in
lakewood ranch so i feel i'm part of
sarasota i am very pleased
to introduce to you not only the number
one international best-selling author
today john loftus but a personal friend
as well
john graduated from boston latin
undergraduate boston college has his
post-doctoral juris doctor work at
suffolk's in georgetown
after graduating from school he went
into the army he was in the intelligence
division of the army and fought and
helped them in the yom kippur's war
when he was done in the army he was
accepted a position in the carter and
reagan administration in the justice
department
he was one of the founding attorneys
in the office of special investigations
that was created for the review of nazi
war criminals living in america
he has appeared on 60 minutes prime time
live
he has appeared on most major networks
cnn all of them
he is probably one of the greatest
recognized authorities on this subject
in the world today
in fact what is interesting when we were
in washington in september
the current head of office of special
investigations for the justice
department met with us eli rosenboom and
he was john's law clerk when john
started with the justice department in
the 70s
i'm also pleased to state that he was
the alfred nominee for the pulitzer pr
surprise uh for the uh pulitzer prize
award uh the book was called the belarus
secret so if you have not had a chance
to read that it is a phenomenal book
please join us
in welcoming john loftus we are very
pleased to have him with us here today
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you
i always get t's doesn't seem a little
bit silly to have an irish catholic
writing books about jews nazis in israel
my mother was born in ireland and she
had an explanation she said there was an
ancient irish legend that the irish of
the lost tribe of israel
my dad shook his head and said john it
couldn't possibly be true that we're
related because the jews can't drink and
the irish can't cook
my association is much more mundane i
was a young ambitious lawyer i had a
great job i worked for the attorney
general the united states
and president carter asked us
for volunteers among the justice
department lawyers to set up a new task
force to investigate whether there were
any nazis hiding in america now since i
knew absolutely nothing about the
subject i of course immediately
volunteered
well i thought it would look good on my
resume i thought i might get a free trip
to germany out of it
instead my boss discovered that i had
some intelligence training when i was an
army officer although everyone thinks
military intelligence is a contradiction
in terms
nevertheless that was the qualification
that got me the most
unusual job
in the u.s government
they raised my security clearances many
levels above top secret my job was to go
through all the cia and nato
intelligence archives for several years
to see if i could find any clues to
where there might be nazis hiding in
america
well i never did get my free trip to
germany
instead i got lots of free trips to
suitland maryland
now suitland is a nice little town it's
right outside washington dc and suitland
is where the u.s government buries its
secrets
literally
there are 20 storage vaults underground
each vault is one acre in size
have you ever seen the movie raiders of
the lost ark
well the last scene of that movie is
what the underground vaults are really
like only not as organized as they are
in the movie
and being a typical man i didn't always
stop and ask for directions and uh one
day i got really lost
and ended up all the way down in the
queue vault where our nuclear warfare
documents were stored
and inside the nuclear vault i stumbled
across a group of nazi files files that
i wasn't supposed to see
files that no one was supposed to see
until the year 2015
and i discovered much to my
embarrassment that many of the nazis
that i had been assigned to prosecute
were already on the government payroll
it was one of those cold war operations
that got all messed up the british
secret service had a private meeting
with a few chaps from our state
department intelligence and the british
said look the germans are defeated now
the russians are the new enemy we have
to get ready for world war iii
and the british were going to recruit
people from all across eastern europe
secretly bring them to america for
training and send them back behind the
iron curtain as freedom fighters
so if world war three ever erupted we
would have an underground army of
freedom fighters behind russian lines
now the only problem with the whole
freedom fighter project was that the
chap in charge of it in britain
was named kim philby
oh i see some of you get the joke
already
kim philby we discovered to our horror
years later kim philby was the highest
ranking communist spy ever to infiltrate
the british secret service so naturally
kim philby was following his orders from
moscow he wasn't sending anti-communists
to america he was sending us the dregs
of the nazi war criminals of eastern
europe and our state department was too
stupid and too gullible to realize they
were being conned until finally when
phil b showed up at a press conference
in moscow in 1963 our bureaucrats do
what all good bureaucrats do they buried
their mistakes
they hadn't told the cia or the
president or congress what the state
department had done now the state
department couldn't destroy all the top
secret nazi documents because it
literally takes too much paperwork to
destroy a top secret file
but you can misfile them
that's why all the nazi files ended up
down in the nuclear vaults where no one
was supposed to find them until i was
stupid enough to stumble across them
some four decades later
i looked at some of the famous american
names who had been innocently involved
with this freedom fighter project i knew
it would be a huge scandal but uh
maybe i'm a thick-headed irishman but i
figured that my dad's generation didn't
fight world war ii to make america safe
for nazi retirement
but i followed the law i went to the cia
in the pentagon and i asked all the
intelligence agencies
for legal permission
to go public
a lot of people may knock america but
you live in one of the few countries in
the world that has the guts to admit its
mistakes and correct them
and i was very very proud of my country
the day the cia called the justice
department
and said that i had permission
to speak
now what do you do when you have a crazy
story like this nazis in america
i pick up the phone and i call 60
minutes
we had a great time mike wallace gave me
30 minutes on his show it's the longest
segment that 60 minutes has ever done
and when the episode about nazis in
america went on the air back in 1982 it
caused a minor national uproar congress
demanded hearings mike wallace got the
emmy award my family got the death
threats it was a great trade-off
but i figured i'd done my boy scout duty
i left washington and i
went back and joined the largest
corporate law firm in boston time to get
on with my life then a funny thing
happened
it seemed as if every retired
intelligence agent in nato started
showing up at my law firm
they all these wonderful stories to tell
because like i guess there weren't many
lawyers running around who had had s.i
and cosmic security clearances
so the deal is they could talk to me
anonymously under the attorney private
client privilege
but my legal requirements are every book
i write has to be submitted first for
censorship through the intelligence
community
so
i was a safe middleman
for many men and women intelligence
community who wanted to be
whistleblowers but do it legally they
had some amazing stories to tell
one of the stories that i was not
allowed to write about my first book was
how the nazis actually got to america
from europe
and the cia said no no no you can't ever
write about the vatican
i'm an irish catholic and this well when
they told me i couldn't write up it only
annoyed me
so as a good lawyer i found the loophole
we had a young
[Music]
british kid who spoke fluent
serbo-croatian now i knew that the
vatican had actually had a network of
croatian catholic priests
who had set up a rat line a smuggling
system for the british secret service
and so the nazis would go from germany
to austria there was a whole network of
convents and monasteries that would take
them down to rome to the port of genoa
where ships were charted to sail them to
australia or latin america or canada
eventually to the united states
so my
young friend
went around with a tape recorder posing
as a young croatian fascist
and these old priests bragged into this
tape recorder how the smuggling program
had worked then i went back to ci and
said look they blew the whistle on
themselves you can't stop me now so it
was lots of fun
we got all sorts of documents
declassified and the book became unholy
trinity it's about the vatican the nazis
and the swiss banks
still scandals going on i hope people
understand that 99 of the catholic
church had no involvement with this this
was a small group
of right
ultra-conservative
italian clerics
who
disgrace the catholic church with
their attitudes both during and after
the war
so the book was very controversial but
it's been published down i guess 12 or
13 languages and
uh i think abroad it's published under
the title rat lines it was made into a
film over here
but that was sort of fun but uh you know
that's two books about nazis and you
know this was kind of interfering with
my law practice and let's face it nazi
hunting is not exactly a growth industry
is it
but by this time i become very friendly
with a lot of men and women in the
intelligence community
and they had sponsored me to join their
retired spy clubs
and i tried very politely to tell them
to go away i just didn't want to do this
stuff anymore and one day one of them
said john you don't get it
if you think what we did with the nazis
was bad let us tell you what we did to
the jews
i heard them out and i read their files
and one day i went home and told my wife
i was leaving the practice of law
for the rest of my life i was going to
be the lawyer
for these men to take a dollar from each
of them
and help these men and women get their
stories told
you see i believe that one-third of the
20th century was classified
it's buried down in those vaults
so as a case study i asked nearly 500
intelligence agents to tell me every
dirty trick we ever pulled on israel
thought it'd be a nice little book it
ended up to be almost 700 pages
don't worry you don't have to read the
whole book we put bulleted paragraphs at
the beginning of each chapter that
summarizes it so you can skim the whole
book at 10 or 20 minutes
we did that for the press
but uh there is a theme to the book and
it's um
towards israel you know what's our
foreign policy towards israel well
everyone knows america is on israel's
side we really are
we non-jews republican democrat we
consistently
keep electing congressmen and senators
who support israel's
cause in the middle east we send more of
our tax dollars to israel than any other
nation on earth we're not the problem
the problem is that for the better part
of the 20th century our state department
and our intelligence community had a
radically different foreign policy
they had said whatever we might say
about liking the jews in public it
really is in america's long-term
national interest to obtain the cheap
and consistent supply of oil
it's not about conspiracy it's not about
bigotry
it's about oil it's about greed
if moses had turned right and settled in
kuwait
we probably would have made israel the
51st state but they had no oil
they had no oil and part of the price
that the arab nations wanted us to pay
was to give them intelligence assistance
in their wars with israel
and sad to say
american intelligence agreed
the bottom line was harsh
in every war that israel fought
american intelligence fought on the arab
side
we wiretapped israel's communications we
betrayed them to the arabs
probably the worst thing
we ever did
to israel was the time we did nothing
and that happened in 1973.
u.s code breakers had deciphered
a russian telegram from their embassy in
lebanon and that telegram revealed to us
the exact hours dates time and place of
an upcoming arab sneak attack against
israel
the
implication was clear
israel was about to be
crushed under a wave of our military
a decision was made to the nixon white
house not to tell the jews
you see henry kissinger although he was
jewish himself was very angry at israel
at the time
kissinger had been trying to put
together a comprehensive middle east
peace solution
you know keep the arabs happy so the oil
would flow
and the stiff-necked israelis were
whining about picky little details like
security you know
so kissinger was furious he agreed that
israel should not be worn until the last
hours two before the attack and even
then they would have to hold their lines
and wait for the arabs to fire the first
shot
now
the
decision to hold information back caused
an enormous amount of israeli casualties
and kissinger later
discusses one of his friends the idea
was
to let israel quote get bloodied a
little bit but come out ahead kiss and
you wanted to slap the wrists of the
israeli leaders so they'd be more
cooperative
now in addition kissinger went to the
secretary of defense and he asked him to
stall off sending any american supplies
to israel for the first seven days of
the yom kippur war
why seven days
israel only had a seven day battle stock
of ammunition and by the seventh day
that kissinger predicted the israeli
leaders would be on their knees ready to
sign any piece of paper that kissinger
put in front of them no matter how
pro-arab but the arabs would be happy
and the oil would flow now kissing
wasn't a bigot he wasn't even a
particularly evil man
he was just a military incompetent
kissinger didn't realize that his little
pressure games
weren't causing israel to bleed a little
bit
it started a hemorrhage that almost
destroyed the nation
but luckily there was one guy in the
white house
that saved israel
no it wasn't richard nixon don't even
get me started on richard nixon
you know actually in my own defense when
i first wrote this book the secret war
against the jews
i got a great deal of flack even from
people the jewish community because i
said very clearly that president richard
nixon was an extreme anti-semite
no one believed
and what happened last year
all the nixon tapes were released from
the national archives
my favorite nixon tape is where he turns
to a friend of his in the oval office
and said
you know if i were to drop an atomic
bomb on tel aviv there would still be
american jews stupid enough to vote for
me
no it's true nixon hated jews but
luckily for israel nixon was involved
with the watergate affair at the time
the guy that saved israel
was that heroic republican the white
house chief of staff general alexander
haig
on the morning of the first day of the
yom kippur war general hague
called his israeli counterpart and
warned him of what kissinger was up to
no supplies for seven days it was a
catastrophe and then general hague told
the israelis a secret the us army had
just perfected a new top secret weapon
called the tow missile
now the tow missile is a dandy little
toy it's like a nintendo game
you have these electronic binoculars
attached to a cable
in the back of the missile and as the
missile flies down range it unwinds
almost two miles of cable behind it
so as you follow an enemy tank with your
binoculars up and down hill and around a
tree you're actually steering the
missile up and down hill and around the
tree
and a 13 year old kid can trace runaway
enemy tanks at full speed and kill them
97 times out of a hundred
to this day the tow missile is one of
the deadliest anti-tank systems on the
planet
al haig said he'd give the tow missile
to israel behind kissinger's back
on the evening of the first day of the
arm kipper war and unmarked plane flew
41 israeli army commanders to a secret
base inside fort benning georgia i know
about this part of the story firsthand
because i was there you see i was the
young army officer who trained the
israelis in the tow missile system
we rushed the israelis through a crash
course at fort benning and then we
stripped every tow missile we had from
the eastern seaboard of the u.s and we
flew them to israel at night
as all the north later discovered you
can pack a lot of tow missiles into one
or two aircraft
at first we thought the israelis had
screwed up we wanted them to put the tow
missiles in a defensive barrier around
the major israeli seas to save as many
lives as possible
and instead those crazy jews took all of
the tow missiles and dumped them at two
spots out in the desert
and they were right
israeli intelligence knew that the
entire egyptian tank army was about to
come roaring up the sinai for the final
assault on israel
but all of those hundreds and hundreds
of egyptian tanks and armored personnel
carriers would have to go through either
the midla or the gitla pass
and when they did
the tow missiles were waiting just in
time they just arrived a few hours
earlier
it was one of the greatest tank
slaughters in modern military history
but to protect al hague
the government of israel told you a
cover story
they told you that the israeli air force
had blown up all those hundreds of
egyptian tanks that's good shooting
so good in fact the american air force
got jealous
the u.s government actually sent a team
of american officers to israel to walk
the battlefield
but there was a problem
they couldn't find any holes on the tops
of the egyptian tanks
they hadn't been hit from the sky at all
they've been blown up from the side that
was the first combat deployment of the
thomas
and i tell that story to illustrate that
sometimes american jews don't know who
your friends are and who your enemies
are one of the old spies said that henry
kissinger should be compelled to change
his religious affiliation from jewish to
self-promotion
that may be a bit unfair to poor henry
who was after all only following a
consistent
american diplomatic policy of siding
with the arabs
in the long run it was about money
there's uh
a few pages in my book the secret war
against the jews
that talked
about our unusual banking system some of
my intelligence friends had stumbled
across i'm going to break a major news
story today with you
it seems
that during world war ii
the leading nazi industrialists
secretly owned a bank in new york city
that bank was dissolved in 1951.
however the records are clear
the nazi bank in manhattan
was run by president bush's father
prescott bush
and by herbert walker his grandfather
the bush family
was on the wrong side of world war ii
now we need to put this in perspective
these are serious serious charges we
have them
the ownership of the nazi bank proof
from three different sources
the bush membership and the border that
bank is a matter of public record
let's put it back in context
after world war one
the leading
german steel magnet august tisson was
very upset because the ally sees some of
his companies for war reparations and he
was determined never to have this happen
in the next war so he set up a series of
banks
one in berlin named after himself the
august tisson bank
one in holland which had been neutral
during world war ii
there was the bang for shipwrecked on
handle
and then
a bank in manhattan
the union banking corp
so no matter which side won the next war
his corporations could move their stocks
and bonds from one bank to the other
now he even trained his two sons
that they would have to preserve the
family business the next war so he told
one son that he would be a nazi and the
other son that he would be in neutral
so no matter which side won the war the
tysons would win
now the first thing the tisson family
needed was money
so they went to a major investment firm
brown brothers harriman in manhattan now
this firm
was was founded by herbert walker and
he merged with a british firm brown
brothers with a major democratic firm
harriman the democrats have their own
scandal here as well
avril harriman's brother roland harriman
was also on the board
it is a matter of public record that
brown brothers harriman
helped american investors move billions
of dollars into germany during the
twenties and thirties
the german currency was worthless but
german stock was worth a fortune because
germany had almost a high-tech
patent monopoly on all these advanced
trade processes
so
the brown brothers harriman helped
organize the flow of money into germany
from some famous american families like
the rockefellers the ford's and the
duponts
now none of these people the bushes
the fords of rockefellers were pro-nazis
they actually favored the conservative
monarchist catholics party in germany
but they did fund hitler as a side bet
because he was useful to keep the unions
at bay so in 1923
money flowed from brown brothers
harriman in new york
to the the dutch bank
to berlin now we've traced from the
dutch bank directly to the nazi party
headquarters that's where the money came
from to build the very first nazi party
headquarters the brown house in munich
fritz tisson later admitted that he was
the man who financed hitler's first
campaign the tyson family
were the great steel and coal combines
of germany they were the heart
of the third reich's armament industry
they were actually larger and wealthier
than the famous krupp family but the
tyson name was kept quiet
now
as hitler came to power the tysons were
making a fortune
but the problem was they were a little
concerned that hitler would push the
german economy to its limits and cause a
great deal of inflation so the tysons
betrayed hitler
they started to move their money out in
the 30s
in essence it was a huge tax fraud they
would sell one of their companies for
example the holland america investment
company to the bushes supposedly a
neutral bank in new york not knowing
that the tissons secretly owned both
banks
it looked like the tysons were losing
money
so the bushes would buy the banks the uh
the companies from the tysons and they'd
set up american branches prescott bush
was the head of uh several of the
companies that were actually directly
owned by the test to some people
now hitler suspected
that uh the the tysons were cheating him
right and left
and tyson
was smart by the time that hitler
declared war on poland tyson figured the
game was up
and he fled the country and proclaimed
himself to be an anti-nazi the truth was
he was making profit on both sides
as were the rockefellers as were the
fords and duponts and bushes to be fair
once they had invested in germany what
they were going to do they couldn't
emigrate with a steel mill
their money was trapped there so
rather than take the loss
some very greedy people
made a war made a war profit
and while american and british soldiers
died they were making millions
the
to hide his records from the british
tyson moved them to the dutch branch
during world war ii now when the nazis
overran holland
the tyson had to hide the records again
so they moved them back to the august
tisson bank in berlin
because there had been a nazi custodian
appointed who was actually another tyson
employee
so they hid all the secret stock
ownerships for the new york bank and the
dutch bank
and they hit all the bank accounts in
these underground vaults in the tyson
bank in berlin
now the u.s government was also studying
the matter
and our alien property custodians
decided that this little new york bank
that the bushes ran
was the subsidiary of a dutch bank and
once the dutch overran holland it was a
nazi bank so believe it or not the u.s
government quietly seized
president bush's father and
grandfather's business holdings as nazi
fronts
these properties were quietly returned
after the war because after all they
were just dutch banks when the dutch got
their bank back so did the bushes
of course it wasn't a dutch bank at all
it never was
it was always always
secretly owned by the leading nazi
industrialists in europe
the
comic opera continued in 1951
the allied investigators finally gave up
trying to
find the missing tissue money fritz
tisson the nazi brother
was actually held in an american prison
in germany for more than four years
and we grilled him where did the money
go he said oh the nazis took all my
money
you know i don't own anything anymore
you know it went out to relatives and
things i don't have anything so he was
lying through his teeth he said i don't
have any foreign bank accounts well that
was technically true he didn't have
foreign bank accounts he owned foreign
banks
so
one of the reasons that uh tyson
got away with it
was that he had a very good lawyer and
his lawyer was alan dulles
now alan dulles
was in charge of u.s intelligence
investigations in germany after the war
it was very convenient because alan
dulles was also the lawyer for the
tissons
and also the lawyer for the bushes
the law firm of sullivan cromwell to
which alan dallas and his brother
belonged was actually the law firm that
handled most these bank transactions and
set up the companies they were the
people who helped direct american
investment in germany during the 20s and
30s and now it's up to the dulles
brothers to help their clients get their
money back in particular the
rockefellers had a huge chunk of money
in brown brothers harriman which the
bushes had invested in the tissot empire
and the rockefellers had no sense of
humor about going broke they wanted
their money back
and so in 1951 everything had quieted
down
alan dulles and his brother were about
to become members of the eisenhower
administration
the new york bank that the bushes ran
was quietly liquidated now the bush
prescott bush and walker each got one
share of stock worth three quarters of a
million dollars
so the bush family took out 1.5 million
dollars in 1951
that's where the bush family fortune
came from
it came from the third reich
right
now is it blood money
yes the tysons were among the largest
slave holders
in the nazi empire they
they used that huge coal mines where
they used jewish slave laborers
as if they were disposable chemicals
um the tissue steel
was the the united steel the rainy da
stalwecker was the heart of the nazi war
machine
but they all got their money back after
the war
the tysons slowly brought the money out
of hiding from new york and argentina
and began to rebuild
in 1971 they merged with another bank
and form the tissue borne a missile
group
chase manhattan bank in new york owns 31
percent of this holding company
it's now worth 50
billion
dollars
so all the poor jewish survivors in
american pows are trying to sue the
swiss banks
when the bush family may have laundered
more money than all the swiss banks
combined
the tyson bournemissa group
consists of assets that were nazi assets
and fraudulently hidden
from both the u.s and british
governments there's no question about
this because the u.s and british
interrogation files are in our national
archives
now i happen to have written a bit about
the bush family's connection with union
bank because i was tipped off
and in my book the secret war against
the jews
i repeated this curious charge the book
the bush family had been on the board of
directors of these curious entities that
seem to have invested in nazi germany
well really to be fair to the bushes
they had just simply invested in the 20s
before hitler really came to power
you know it was not a crime maybe it
wasn't moral to investigate nazi germany
but before america became involved in
war it wasn't illegal
but after the war
you know it seems that young george bush
who later became president dropped out
of yale
because he knew that in a week his
father's firms were going to be seized
as nazi fronts
and young george bush uh wanted to
enlist in the military to save the
family honor
the younger bush generations i think
have a a great deal of credit to their
names and have indeed done america proud
i mean but let's be fair no one blames
the democrats because jack kennedy's dad
bought nazi stocks how many people here
knew that joseph kennedy invested in
nazi germany
everyone knows that
how many of you knew before today
that the bush family ran a nazi bank
okay now
we haven't released this before the
election this has got to come out
because it's much more important
than just whether you know prescott
bush's grandson
runs for office
this whole issue of being able to hide
money through multi-national shells has
a direct effect on our political system
it's not just a question of double
punching ballots
the more important question is
who's funding
our political campaigns
perhaps there are only rumors but the
allegations i have received from the
intelligence community are the tyson
family
are the secret sources of that slush
fund in germany that helmut cole
uh refuses to disclose whether he's from
that they were the secret financial
backers of their neighbor in london they
live right across the street from
margaret thatcher
and at the tissens and their business
partners the rockefellers
have been the wall street ring of the
republican party financing candidates
for the last 40 years in the u.s
that there is this almost bottomless
slush fund of campaign money
there are numerous tissue outlets in the
u.s so legally tested employees in
america can donate money to little
campaigns
and i don't know if he will ever know
how much of that money was actually
donated by tissen employees and how much
was reimbursed from abroad
reimbursements from abroad are of course
a felony
foreign corporations may not contribute
to american things so perhaps when we
sit down in congress in a few weeks
and begin to debate
how best to reform our ballot counting
system
we should also take a look at campaign
finance reform
[Applause]
[Music]
you know there's one thing that all of
us republicans and democrats can agree
on is that nazis are bad
and we have always suspected
that someone was pulling strings
and i think what we have had is a series
of multinational corporations behaving
like pirates
and they have no ideology they don't
care about america they don't care about
nazi germany they only care about
money
but what do i care
i'm not a jew
none of my family died in the holocaust
i don't have any relatives in israel
why give up a great legal career to go
around writing history books
not only is it not profitable it's like
doing homework for the rest of your life
well i have a personal reason for
staying with this subject and being the
president of the florida holocaust
museum
that's sort of fun if you haven't been
to see us
that we just built the fifth
largest holocaust museum in the world in
saint petersburg florida and i missed a
meeting and they made me president
that's what happens
but we're investing a quarter million
dollars here in sarasota to open up a
branch of the museum and we're
opening investing a quarter of a million
dollars in january we'll have america's
largest website so every child in
america
can take one of these high-tech virtual
reality tours of our museum and they can
walk from room to room 360 degree views
and
and actually meet with a holocaust
survivor and type in questions and get
answers so kids can learn a little bit
about character education about
tolerance about racial prejudice about
world war ii about the holocaust
because we need to do a better job the
job of teaching our children
but as for me
i have a personal reason for staying on
this subject
see when i was down in those
intelligence vaults
i came across a manuscript that would
change my life
it was written
by a jew
his name was saul schneider
saul lived in that little borderland
between poland and russia today we call
it belarus but in those days before
world war ii
the jews called it the pale the pale of
settlement there used to be a 70 mile
wide strip of land along the russian
borders where jews have been allowed to
live for three centuries
and you could go from vilna to minsk to
baranovich to pinck all the way down to
romania and some of these cities and
towns were 90 jewish
the pale was the most densely populated
jewish settlement on the face of the
earth
unfortunately for them it lay right
smack in the middle of hitler's invasion
path for russia
now when the armies of the third reich
came pouring through they didn't have
enough german soldiers to take care of
this huge jewish population
so the ss asked the local christian
population for volunteers and sad to say
there's always one percent in every
country including ours
who would volunteer to climb the power
over the bodies of children if necessary
now the volunteer that came to be in
charge of saul's life
was a man named dr stankovic a doctor of
humanities which is rather ironic to the
jews because they soon identified dr
stankovic as the inventor of the sardine
method of execution
dr stankovic would have his police force
drag the jewish families out to a road
where ditches had been dug they were
forced at gunpoint to disrobe then they
had a climb in the ditches and lay on
top of each other head to toe
that way stankovich's police could shoot
through a double layer of bodies and
save ammunition
you know a bullet cost one mark 25 cents
so they would shovel a layer of dirt
over the dead and wounded a double-air
bodies a layer of dirt and so on and so
on
now the worst part of the sardine method
wasn't even discovered until after world
war ii when american red cross doctors
were conducting autopsies on the graves
they could find no evidence of wounds
upon the smallest victims
apparently to save the price of a bullet
dr stankovich ordered that the babies be
buried alive
as a reward for his efficiency the ss
promoted dr stankovic and made him the
governor of the entire province of
baranovich where saul lived
there were fifty thousand jews in the
baranovich ghetto on the day that dr
stankovich arrived six months later
there were five thousand jews
six months after that only 500 jews were
kept alive
as skilled laborers in dr stankovic's
concentration camp now saul was the camp
barber saul had lost his wife his three
kids all 110 members of his family now
think about that
every relative every friend every face
he had known on the face of the earth
had been murdered
and this little jewish barber did an
amazing thing
he dug a tunnel under a nazi
concentration camp
and led the last 126 jews in a breakout
they made it to the swamps and forests
of beela russia they joined up with
other jewish fugitives but they didn't
run away
they formed a jewish resistance brigade
a partisan brigade bjelski's brigade
hundreds of miles behind nazi lines this
tiny group of jewish men and women most
of them teenagers early 20s
they took up arms and went back and
fought against the men that had
slaughtered their families the jewish
women in particular were so adept at
blowing up railway lines they were
crippling hitler's supply trains trying
to reach the eastern front they were
changing the course of the war
stankovic put a price of ten thousand
marks on saul's head
six of the bolaris ss police battalions
were assigned
to track the jews down
at the end of world war ii bjelski's
brigade was the most highly decorated
partisan unit on the entire eastern
front but there were only a few dozen
survivors
saul was one
at the end of the war
saul had remarried a young woman whose
life he'd saved in the camp and she was
pregnant
saul didn't want to have his child grow
up under communism
so he and his young bride took up their
arms again they shot their way across
the russian border escaped across
central europe and eventually emigrated
to the united states
when he got here
saul settled in central new jersey
but he didn't put the past behind him he
sat down and wrote out his histories
of the 50 000 jews from his little
corner of the world who would never be
able to speak for themselves and proudly
saul sent a copy to the u s government
and someone somewhere in our state
department
stamp saul's manuscript secret
and they hid it down the nuclear vault
with the nazi files you know why
as one of their anti-communist agents
the british secret service had recruited
dr stankovic
it gets worse
the british asked us to hide him and we
did we brought dr stankovic to new york
city and gave him a job as a broadcaster
at radio liberty your tax dollars at
work
please remember was the mccarthy era no
one believed these crazy comedy charges
about war criminals in america
and stankovic played them like a flute
by 1952
he had resettled virtually the entire
nazi puppet government of yellow russia
to the town of south river new jersey
i couldn't believe the files i actually
took some federal bodyguards and went to
see south river one night you know they
have a private cemetery for the belarus
ss
and inside the cemetery is the monument
engraved nazi president
behind their local church they have a
monument to their ss division
and you know the worst thing about south
river new jersey
all this time
saul had been living less than a half an
hour away
and i thought what a tragedy
here is this heroic jew who fought
against the nazis and the communists and
came to america to find freedom only to
end up living in the shadow of the men
who murdered his own babies
what would you do
know maybe i am a thick-headed irishman
but i went to the assistant attorney
general of the united states and i asked
permission to prosecute a british
intelligence agent as a nazi war
criminal i showed him the stankovich
file
permission was granted
secretly i asked all the u.s agencies to
put a trace out for saul snaddow as a
key witness in the future trial of dr
stankovic
but all the agencies reported back
negative
no trace
saul was missing it in view of his age
had to be presumed dead
it was terribly sad but it didn't stop
our trial preparations
i had my staff
round up every nazi document in the
world that even mentioned dr stankovic
it really was an enormous research job
and you know dr stankovic was ungrateful
enough to drop dead on me two weeks
before we could file charges against him
he died peacefully in his bed as citizen
of the united states
there was a big sigh of relief over the
british embassy
and the british government asked the new
reagan administration which had just
come in not to let me investigate any
more cases like that
much too embarrassing to the british
government because if they open up the
nazi files that's going to lead to the
vatican then you're gonna have to deal
with the nazi gold
and where the nazi money went
and that would lead back to americans as
well as british so you know the british
said use our 75-year censorship rule we
won't release any of the nazi files for
75 years
so
i was ordered by the us government for
reasons of foreign policy
to stay out of the vaults and forget
what i had seen
but how how do you forget about someone
like saul
i told the reagan administration that i
would not participate in a cover-up and
i sat down and wrote the manuscript to
my first book
and i dedicated it to saul a jew who
bore witness to the holocaust
and to meg
my newborn so that she may never have to
that's why i did it
did it for our kids for all our kids
it's why i volunteer my time
at the florida holocaust museum
we have to make the world a better
safer place for our children
and that means in some small part that
people like me have to dig out the ugly
truth
and we all of us have to recognize that
the truth is more important than
politics
we need to regain control of our history
we cannot live in a world where one
third of our modern history is
classified
in the end i remain optimistic very
optimistic about america i guess i am
still at heart an eagle scout
and some good things have happened when
we went to build our holocaust museum we
smuggled a box car out of poland
it's the only one the polish government
hasn't cleaned up first and when we were
setting the car up inside the museum we
found something horrible inside
maybe something wonderful we found a
little girl's ring
now all we know for sure from the silver
marks inside
is that ring existed at about the time
of the holocaust
we know that there were once five jewels
of some kind that had been set in the
ring
and we know that the ring would fit the
hand of a about a 14 year old girl
that's all we really know for sure but
you know what happened
50 years ago somewhere in europe a
little girl took the jewels out of a
ring to try and ransom her survival
and one day
as she was riding in that box car she
realized that for her there would be no
survival and for whatever reason with
that little
empty ring with all the jewels gone it
was still valuable to her and she didn't
want the nazis to get it so she took it
off her hand and put it in a crack in
the floorboard and hammered it in with
her heel
and he did it so no one would find her
and 50 years later by a miracle we
picked that boxcar
to bring to st petersburg florida
the little girl's ring is mounted
outside
as we take the school kids through
we teach them a story of hope but ours
is not a sad museum
there are no atrocity phones but kids
need to understand the past to prevent
it from happening again and when we show
them little girls ring we say you know
don't be sad that we don't know that
little girl's name and don't be sad that
all the jewels are lost
because the jewels aren't lost
you are the jewels
all of you who care about the jewels of
justice
of memory of understanding of tolerance
you
are the gems of american society
and people like you
preserve the truth preserve our history
because the most important thing that i
learned from saul
was that in this country
you should never be afraid to speak the
truth thank you for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
john loftis remarks were part of the
sarasota reading festival in florida his
book on holy trinity the vatican the
nazis and the swiss banks was published
by saint martin's press
[Music]